here we go
time for this week's sin city chronicles
a weekly look back at vegas history and
happenings
april 12 1987 was a big night for you
too
[Applause]
first they had their joshua tree concert
at the thomas and mack and
after the show they filmed the iconic
video for i still haven't found what i'm
looking for
it was shot downtown on fremont street
the video it was done
in one take and took less than three
hours to film and was nominated for four
mtv video music awards
on april 14th 1993 paul mccartney kicked
off his new world tour at sam boyd
stadium
the tour spent the entire year and
circled the globe
the vegas show was a sellout and if you
stayed for the encore
you were treated to beatles hits like i
saw her standing there
and hey jude april 17th 1999 the las
vegas thunder
they played their last game in las vegas
the ihl team played
six seasons at the thomas and mack and
two of the seasons
they were division champs the team
folded on april
18th because they had no arena to play
in the following season
the liberace museum opened on april 15
1979
it was located on east tropicana and at
its peak the museum was drawing 450
000 visitors per year and the museum
closed in 2010
happy birthday to brendan yuri uh he's
the lead singer of panic at the disco
brendan moved to las vegas when he was
two years old
and graduated from palo high school
brennan celebrated his birthday on
april 12th and that's your sin city
chronicles